(crowd cheering and clapping)
- Very excited, we're very excited.
I'm gonna be so cool and
you're never gonna know.
- I'm gonna be so cool.
- Only so cool.
- My mom is just gonna be like
how did you not freak out?
I'm so cool and fine.
But you're not originally from Texas?
- No.
- But you love it so much you moved there.
- I did. I moved to Austin.
- Yeah it's great.
- Yeah, it's a good place.
I was there when you won.
- You were?
- I was.
- Oh, wow
- Did you vote for Justin or me?
(laughter)
I'm just kidding.
Don't tell me.
(laughter)
- No, no, look, the good
thing is that you won.
It doesn't matter who
I voted for, does it?
No it does not.
- It does.
No, I'm just kidding.
It's a great place though.
It's such a fun place.
- I love Austin.
Austin has the vibe of
whatever you have going on.
It's okay.
- And that's what.
- Do you know what I mean?
- It's inclusive, yeah.
Agreed, agreed.
So where do you spend most
of your time these days?
- In bed, no I'm just kidding.
(laughter)
- I want your life.
- Right now LA, because
of the kids are in school.
So you go where the kids are happening.
- Yeah me too.
Me too yeah.
But wait, so your kids are they 11 and 8?
- 11 and 8.
- 11, 8 now?
Do you, because COVID was
whoop, like I'm gonna get her,
- Do that again, she goes
whoop-whoop, she's got a license.
I go whoop. And like, everyone's gone.
(laughter)
- No,
- No, no, no, no, no, no,
no I'm nervous about it.
Just do it. Do it, do it.
- Whoop.
(laughter)
I'm not going to do it again.
- That's not, why I
didn't vote for - I know.
- I know I won't do it on command.
I can't, I've noticed am sweating,
- Why're you sweating?....
- 'cause I'm a huge fan, but I'm fine.
- your Kelly Clarkson -I am fine.
- You are on my Wayfair app.
- You are literally, every
movie you've ever made.
I know I literally just
watched the Net again the other
anyway, so here we go.
- You can't look at my
stuff and buy something?
- I can't even look at you for
a long period. I don't know